maintenant, après notre deuxième place dans
l'Iowa, nous avons prié et délibéré sur la
voie à suivre si je
pouvais faire quelque chose pour produire un résultat favorable
plus d'arrêts de campagne plus d'interviews je
le ferais mais je ne peux pas demander à nos
partisans de se porter volontaires  du temps et
font don de leurs ressources si nous n'avons pas
de chemin clair vers la victoire. Par conséquent, je
suspends aujourd'hui ma campagne. Il me semble clair
qu'une majorité des électeurs de la République et des primaires
veulent donner à Donald Trump une autre
chance de voir sa présidence se faire
bloquer par une résistance implacable.  et ils
voient les démocrates utiliser la loi ce jour pour
l'attaquer. J'ai eu des désaccords avec
Donald Trump, comme sur la pandémie du virus Corona
et son élévation d'Anthony
Fouchy. Trump est supérieur à l'actuel
président sortant Joe Biden, c'est clair, j'ai
signé un engagement à soutenir  le
candidat républicain et moi honorerons cet
engagement qu'il a mon soutien parce que nous
ne pouvons pas revenir à la vieille
garde républicaine d'antan, un reconditionnement formé du
corporatisme réchauffé que Nikki
Haley représente